freunde also jetzt können wir alles
sehen so groß ist dass heftig also das
war die riesen explosion
hey leute viele von euch haben unter das
monster squad video darunter geschrieben
dass sie eine nukleare explosion wollen
und die haben auch alle einen daumen
hoch gegeben deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht dass ich das jetzt mache ich
habe das hier müssen wir meinen tollen
rats tons gilt sie einfach mal überhaupt
nicht vorhanden sind gemacht ich weiß
dass die ganzen spaß dieses wiederum
meckern von wegen du kannst ja schon so
machen
ja danke ich mache das aber nach meiner
art und ich kann also überhaupt nicht an
euch alle die das hier angucken und
zufrieden sind high luca cool dass ich
hier seid also ich wäre das jetzt
einfach in der luft fliegen lassen
ich habe auch nicht so viel nur klärte
genommen weil sonst mein pc einfach
abstützen wird dass es unglaublich
zeitaufwendig bzw nuclear auch wenn ich
an ressourcen aufwendig und ich werde
einfach eine fackel hinsetzen da wie das
alles angezündet weil ich hatte
natürlich feuerzeuge drin
und jetzt könnt ihr einfach mal die show
genießen ich glaube dass mein pc
abstützen wird diese kuh da hinten wird
erst mal sterben jetzt hakt ist ich kann
meine maus nicht mehr bewegen das ist
sehr cool gerade ach mensch dort dinge
doch relativ gut klar aber locker
tag sagt okay wir haben ein riesiges
loch
alter ist das krass ich könnte jetzt mal
ganz kurz noch hier moment hier so ein
bisschen nachhelfen sage ich mal immer
noch so ein bisschen mehr hier anpacken
alters ist schon krass
ich sehe das ende da hinten nicht mehr
das ist nicht mehr aufgebaut alters ist
so unnormal krasnow klärte in den
umsätzen war dann auch einzeln jetzt
wird sie gleich er widerhaken und ich
flieg eigentlich geradeaus und gleich
wird ist einfach übels haken oder ich
befinde mich gar nicht im block radius
von der witzigen ich weiß es nicht wird
sich hier noch einzeln noch nie
es geht gar nicht jedoch es geht aber
dahinter explodiert gerade von daher hat
das hat alles jetzt geht's dahin
explodierte oder ist explodiert also das
wird auf jeden fall borken jetzt hat
jetzt das wird auf jeden fall heftig so
ich hätte ja nicht gedacht dass es noch
so gut funktioniert eigentlich deswegen
hab ich mir gedacht so ganz spontan dass
ich jetzt noch ein paar andere dran
packe einfach an den rand dann haben wir
nachher einfach dieses gebiets der
explosion die sg eben wie gar weil es
ist nicht mit ihm es ist nicht einfach
nur mit world edit ganz ohne liebe in
block einfach erstellt aus 1000 tnt
es ist einfach nuklearpläne und nukleare
ist noch eine ganz andere liga als
normale freunde also das wird heftig
hier sehen wir wenn ich mir das gleich
angucke es ist ja schon gerade heftig im
gange sieht man allerdings schlecht also
was anders als kraft und heftig habe
jeder aufnahme auch noch nicht gesagt
das tut mir auch sehr leid
allerdings bin ich grad einfach
überwältigt vor allem jetzt von diesen
ganzen strukturen die hier immer der neu
guinea braucht es ist krass
alter ist das krass vor allem dass da
hinten ist auch einfach alles weg
das hat sich nur noch nicht aufgebaut
horst als krass ist das krass freunde
guckt euch das bitte an
ist das noch zu beschreiben ist nicht
mehr das ist einfach nur krass ich
bewege mich auf bett diamanten hey guck
mal hier sind diamanten okay ich glaube
hier findet man auch noch ein paar mehr
aber hey hier sind diamanten flanieren
zwei krass das ist echt einfach nur der
einzige ausdrücklich da zum vorschein
bringen kann es einfach krass zu heftig
und normal und tnt und konkret kapital
abonnieren
das ist echt krass
vor allem einfach weil ich da nicht mal
zum ende gucken kann ich meine männer
des kurz ein bisschen hochstapler auf
normaltarif ist es weil ich das
eigentlich relativ cool finde wenn man
da so den den nebel im hintergrund sieht
allerdings ist es jetzt gerade einfach
nur suboptimal
juli freunde hui hui wenn irgendwer von
euch auf youtube video gesehen mit
10.000 dass ich jetzt heftiger klassen
dungeon empires wird das hier gefragt
wird das hier unglaublich wertvoll junge
ist das ist einfach mal nur bedrock
junge leute ist nur bedrock das hier ist
nur bei grob beschäftigen hier ist man
sich einfach nur bedrock weit und breit
das ist doch einfach mal so krass das
ist doch einfach nur normal freut sich
dass dahinter auch noch auf das da
hinten auch dass hier auch freunde also
jetzt können wir alles sehen so boah ist
das heftig also das war die riesen
explosion
ich hoffe erstmalig hat es gefallen ich
würde mich dann definitiv über einen
daumen hoch freuen auch dass ihr mir
weitere mods einfach in die kommentare
schreibt wenn ihr andere mods mal wieder
vorgestellt haben wollte und alt es ist
alles betrug das ist doch mal so krass
also macht könnt ihr einfach in die
kommentare schreiben bitte einfach den
daumen hoch geben wir das jetzt
unglaublich episch fandet und sonstwo
ist das krass alter ist das krass wir
sind bei mir schnell wieder